[Music]
thank you both so much for being here
and thank you for this film i have so
many questions but i know we have
limited time so
um let me start off with jessica i read
that you
uh interested in tammy bayer had gotten
her life rights back in 2012.
is that right yes i got the rights to
the documentary i was on the press tour
for zerg 30 and i was jet lagged
somewhere and i it was uh on the tv and
i just
i honestly i thought it was an amazing
story that i didn't know
tammy fay
what'd you do hello mother this is jim
baker
my husband
if everyone watching
could double their pledge just for one
month
god loves you he really does
we're not doing anything wrong though
[Music]
they were taken down and the snl
sketches and making fun of her calling
her vulgar and
all these mean
things you know that we
show some comedians saying people say
about her uh in our film
and so that's what i thought i knew and
then i saw the documentary and um i was
just blown away the steve peters
interview to me was just
such an a radical act of love um that
had never really
been acknowledged like why did we care
so much better mascara
you know so i i wanted to um write that
wrong
did your interest in her your
understanding of her shift like in the
film today
did it become something different than
what you were thinking about back in
2012
absolutely so it started you know i just
said i i don't know what i'm doing
because it was the beginning of my
career so i called my agent and manager
i met with
um randy and fenton and bought the
rights
from them
and i called rachel
and she said she wanted to we'd work
together on lawless and she said she
wanted to
work on this
and i called david greenbaum
right when he started at searchlight and
he said
amazing so let me know when you guys
have the script
and he was i believe that was the only
suit he was the only studio we sent it
to
but it was like a long process and
developing the story
definitely it changed i mean in the
beginning i guess like anything
some kind of like piece of art it like
evolves and in the beginning it was this
idea for me of like what's behind the
mask
i kept thinking about that
and then i started
to realize like
well you know she said in an interview
to roseanne
you know everyone kept asking her why do
you wear so much makeup why why she
finally said you know like well i feel
pretty with it
and i got to the point like right
towards the end where i was like why do
we need to justify why she wears makeup
it's no one's business you know
and
um rupaul who narrated her documentary
actually said
that drag isn't a mask it's a revealing
and i love that like that idea that she
is so authentically who she is and she
uses makeup as a revealing of who she
what she feels
and she's so strong about it that she
tattoos her face
so no one can change her um i actually
really admire that you know that's such
an individual authentic thing
so yes it did evolve yeah
rachel um could you talk a bit about the
production the development and then
moving into production when were you in
production and
of course i i don't know how it relates
to covet but i'm assuming you ran into
coveted at some point
yes we did
so um october 31st 2019 was our start
date halloween
and
um it was
uh you know a while back now and we were
in post during covet right at the
beginning of it and we're really
figuring things out
in the you know day to day
and how to work remotely um
you know when we were in toronto for
film festival i think that was the first
time i had seen a movie with an audience
all of us
yeah it was
you know that just as you all know that
just doesn't happen
so um that was an adjustment that we
made over the course of i don't know how
many months and then
we really in search like really wanted
to find the right time to release it so
thankfully we were able to do it once
theaters were back open
um
did was your post-production change by
having to work remotely i mean yeah we
were doing
you know we were doing a lot of the
sound remotely which was kind of crazy
and um
a lot of cuts now you're used to
sitting in a room with your editor and
your director and going through scene by
c and none of that was going on it was
all remote
um
even the color correcting you know
was done
so it was it was challenging but in some
ways it was actually um
it showed you just how involved you
could actually be in terms of the amount
of people that could engage just given
the fact that everybody had access to a
screen
amazing
well it turned out
um jessica i want to go back to
something you you were talking about
earlier you know this notion of artifice
and mask
um
what struck me and your performance in
this film is
like
i don't know how quite how to articulate
it but there's this tension in her
between complete artifice not just the
makeup but she has this
there's a kind of facade but then
there's complete genuine quality to her
and and you see it in public
moments where she's on stage or
performing but also like privately with
jam like this
there are these different layers to her
you know of
naked vulnerability and this kind of
like that laugh and the smile it was
just kind of impenetrable like
positivity i'm just wondering like as a
performer how did you approach that was
that something that you
obviously you must have thought about it
so just anything you could share on her
yeah well this is a character because
she's so much you know um
the accent and then also the pitch of
the voice is much higher than mine and
her mannerisms and her laugh and she
only smiles with her upper lip she
doesn't you know i'm a big toothy smile
um so like all these things the singing
oh gosh you know
the
ministering in front of a lot of extras
who actually
went to ptl like new gym and tv we shot
in north carolina um right next to where
heritage usa is so
all all of that in creating the
character
i started from the outside
and um
and then from there i tried to
understand the inside so i started to
realize that like
i
actually found a great deal of
loneliness in her i found you know her
laugh usually came from
a nervous quality or you know a hand
gesture she would make or like every
time she ate food you know she'd go
like that with her shoulders just so
sweet like how much she loved like
something delicious
um so i started looking at all of all of
these things about her to help me
understand the internal and then also
her books and
you know her kids and um
the documentary filmmakers had hundreds
of hours of unused footage that they let
me watch and study
and one thing i really
noticed is i had to connect like what is
her she's almost this
compulsive like obsession about
connecting with people
like strangers she needs to make
everyone feel loved it's
it was so important to her to reach out
to people to touch them to hold them
and i think it's because she felt
unloved and it started when she was a
child in the pentecostal church
the father leaving the family she became
the embodiment of that shame
and she didn't want anyone else to feel
left out
of love
and so i connected whatever her faith
was to love and so who knows you know
that really happened when she spoke in
tongues when she went to church and had
that moment
i don't know if it's because
god really spoke through her
and i don't know if it's because it's
the first time she felt people worthy of
life and worthy of love and seeing for
the first time and maybe they're the
same thing maybe god is that maybe it is
faith is love
um so i tried to when working on her and
connecting to the interior try to
understand what was
her obsession with connecting to people
and for me it always came from a sense
of
um
sadness
so it's it's juxtaposed like she seems
super positive and happy because she's
always trying to lift herself
back up um to face the world
right as you were talking i flashed on
her relationship with her mother which i
thought was really interesting in the
film to me unexpected initially when i
saw the mom i don't know this horrible
figure of oppression but like tammy
maintained a relationship with her and
wanted to
show her love like with the fur code
until
that's the great cherry jones though too
she brought in so many
i mean guys
like every aspect of cheri she's just
the most wonderful person to work with
on all
fronts and um
she brought in all that warmness i mean
what the incredible thing is
you know
that character was only allowed back in
the church because
she could play the piano and so she
really like
all of her sternness and her harshness
came from wanting to protect her
daughter she didn't want her daughter to
experience
the banishment that she experienced from
the church and she knew what could
happen if you didn't you know if some if
you were outside though you didn't tell
the line and so
she's stern but it all comes from this
like great love she has her daughter and
that's jerry she's just i think a genius
yeah definitely
um
so one thing you know i remember in high
school or college i would watch the ptl
club once in a while it would just be on
it was just like i was not a member of
the evangelical community but i was like
it was fascinating and i would watch it
but i had no real sense of what it was
and to watch the film now i i saw the
whole the cultural context of it of how
the evangelical movement has changed
over time and to see
i mean the financial corruption aside
like the the ptl club to see like where
they began when they were really young
you know it was like sex positive and
inclusive and like she she did share
with the penile like
and it had that emphasis on love and
inclusion and then you have the jerry
falwell who maybe represents where we
are today in that movement where it's
really divisive the culture wars
homophobic all the rest and to see that
in the film i thought was really
interesting and where she kind of
embodied
something that i feel
i don't know if there's that exists in
the
movement today at all that voice but
yeah i'm not sure to me there's
definitely was like a fork in the road
in this time period
and um
i do wonder
what would have happened
had
society allowed tammy or had the church
allowed tammy to keep working
when her husband was convicted and
charged with
crimes allowed her to really
minister in the church
i mean really she was excluded in the
only community who really wrapped their
arms around her was the lgbtq community
um
but yeah i i 100 agree this was the time
um in america where
you know falwell created the religious
right and that coalition and really went
into politics and jim and tammy both
believe that the church should be
outside of politics
did you i'm curious did you ever meet
jim or
i never met jim
um and i you know wondered about i read
his book
here's the reality like our film stops
when he's in prison right for him his
story
and for a woman who was so closely seen
as a um
as the side of her husband and not
really seen on our own i thought it was
really important to really try to focus
on her
separate from jim
and the book he wrote
is a completely different person than
who he is today he's had so many lives i
mean he's in some sense he's kind of
regressed he's he's gone to jerry follow
away i guess one might say
um
and uh
so we really like stopped
from for me
like where the
he was uh when he wrote his book and the
books titled i was wrong
so it was like you kind of felt like he
could have gone one way or another and
then
he went the other
i'm curious
so the film there's the scene
right at the end when he reveals like
what everything's falling apart it's
coming down
um and he goes
let this be you know i'll take the fall
you don't know anything and i'm curious
like as
as an actor how you approach that like
what she knew
and what she didn't know
because
yeah this is a fascinating question
because i get asked this all the time
like what do you think she knew
i mean
it you know in terms of
my personal beliefs i don't believe in
the prosperity doctrine
i think money corrupts i think um the
reality is money is very closely
connected to
the church to all
i mean i was just in italy
and you know there's a lot of money in
the vatican
um
so you know every time you know you go
to sunday service and they pass the
plate around the wallet comes out so
with televangelism it's just a much
larger scale right where it's like okay
you send in your money now you millions
of viewers every sunday doing it so
in my mind
it's
i wonder if faith and um
money
if there's a way to separate them you
know um so it's not an expected thing
that you
pay to um
i don't know i i didn't grow up within
the church so
yes i i that's definitely not something
i follow in terms of what did she know
i don't think she knew about jim baker's
sex scandal until she was told right at
the end
um
because the reality why would he tell
her and he was
paying using church money to pay her off
so that all was i think completely kept
from her
and then in terms of the finances
i loved tammy but i don't think she was
like a financial
person like in those rooms you know i
mean in fact i know it because i talked
to people who
were there she was in no part like
you know
and i don't think actually jim was
probably the smartest when it came to
finances as well
so i just i think um
the whole like idea of buying
partnerships and not having enough rooms
for them i don't think she knew how many
rooms they were selling because the
reality is also she was a drug addict at
the time
so um i think she was just
kind of like sleepwalking through her
life and was not in any financial
meetings
and the us government thinks the same
because they never charged her right
right
um i did want to ask about um
the final scene of her singing at oral
roberts it's an incredible scene your
performance but also the direction of
that scene i mean
um i'd love to hear anything you could
share about that but in terms of
i mean
she's out there on this alone on this
dark stage with a hostile audience she
starts singing
and her face lights up and then the
chorus appears behind her and then we
see it's
in her mind but then it comes back
and the way that scene is built and then
the way she wins over the audience
gradually it's so powerful and moving it
kind of embodies like all that tension
in her of the
relentless positivity and love
with the vulnerability i don't know just
could you talk about how it was to
perform that and build that
scene as an actor that was that and the
steve peter scene for me were the
hardest
because steve peters you can google the
whole things on youtube it's so it's
there right so that makes it like wow
that's really
to live up to that and then the end
there's so much in that last scene about
what we're trying to say about tammy
and a friend of mine um the great family
leader jeff nichols uh was talking to me
about that last scene he goes
you know what that scene it's like all
of a sudden i got it he said there's
some people who just have a gospel choir
always there
and he's like we've met them and you're
like why are you always like this and
then you realize they've got a gospel
choir there behind them that only they
can see
and that's tammy i mean
i love the switching back and forth to
two realities and it's like you say she
wins over the audience
but does she yeah
you know or
what i mean that's tammy in her moment
of this is what it feels like to be in
the grace of god to be like
unconditionally loved that's also what a
lot of movies about to me
and it's people's perception you know
you receive what you put out into the
world and
tammy and for me in that moment it's
like she is like in her
energy like she is that is who she is
right it's like pink lights and there's
sparkles and you know it's like but so
completely over the top
and then yet also it could be quite
complicated and painful like the
american flag and it's like you know god
bless america all these things it's like
tammy's version of what the world of
what this country could be and what it
should be
and then you look at the two realities
and so it's a it's for me i i
i think michael showalter did an amazing
job um directing that final scene
because it's
for me i love her but then i also feel
like ah a bit sad that
the realities look so different
yeah yeah
well i want to thank both of you for
coming out i could talk to you so much
longer but getting the signal you need
to wrap it up
but
join me in thanking
[Applause]
[Music]
you